foreign
when I was 12 years old
I fractured my foot playing soccer
I didn't tell my parents when I got home
that night because the next day my dad
was taking me to see a movie
a soccer movie
I worry that if I told my parents about
the foot they would take me to see a
doctor
I didn't want to see a doctor I wanted
to see the movie
the next morning my dad goes it's nice
out
why don't we walk to the theater
it was a mile away
as we go he says why are you limping I
tell him I have something in my shoe
the movie was spectacular it told the
story of some of soccer's greatest Stars
great Brazilian players I was ecstatic
at the end of the movie I told my dad
about the foot
he took me to see an orthopedic doctor
who put my foot in a cast for three
weeks
I tell you the story today because four
decades later
I don't really consider myself a soccer
fan anymore
today my sports fandom is tuned to
another kind of football
now my 12 year old self wouldn't just
find this incomprehensible
my 12 year old self would see this as a
betrayal
now you might say we all change from the
time we're at 12. so let me fast forward
a decade
when I was 22
I was a freshly minted electronics
engineer in Southern India I had no idea
that three decades later I would be
living in the United States that I would
be a journalist
and that I would be the host of a
podcast called hidden brain it's a show
about human behavior and how to apply
psychological science to our lives
now we didn't have podcasts when I
graduated from college we didn't walk
around with smartphones in our pockets
so my future was not just unknown
it was unknowable
all of us have seen what this is like in
the last three years as we slowly try
and emerge from the covet pandemic if we
think about the people we used to be
three years ago before the pandemic we
can see how we have changed
we can see how anxiety and isolation and
upheavals in our lives and livelihoods
how this has changed us change our
Outlook changed our perspective
but there is a paradox here and the
Paradox is when we look backwards
we can see enormous changes in who we
have become
but when we look forwards
we tend to imagine that we're going to
be the same people in the future
now sure we imagine the world is going
to be different we know that Ai and
climate change is going to mean for a
very different world but we don't
imagine that we ourselves will have
different perspectives different views
different preferences
in the future
I call this the illusion of continuity
and I think one reason this happens is
that when we Look Backwards the contrast
with our prior cells to who we are today
is so clear we can see it so clearly
that we have become different people
when we look forward we can imagine
ourselves being a little older a little
grayer but we don't imagine
fundamentally that we're going to have a
different Outlook or a different
perspective that we're going to be
different people and so those changes
seem more amorphous
I want to make the case to you today
that this illusion has profound
consequences not just for whether we
become soccer players or podcast hosts
but for matters involving life and death
let me introduce you to John and
Stephanie rinka we did a story about
them for hidden brains some years ago
this Photograph was taken in 1971 on
their wedding day
John and Stephanie had just eloped
gotten married at Cambridge City Hall in
Massachusetts he was 22 she was 19.
John told me that after they got married
they traveled to different parts of the
country they eventually settled in North
Carolina John became a high school
basketball coach
Stephanie became a nurse
and because they lived in a rural part
of the state she would often make house
visits to patients many of the patients
she saw were very sick they had terminal
illnesses very low quality of life and
when Stephanie came home from these
visits she was often shaken
and she would tell John
John if I ever get a terminal illness
please do nothing to prolong my
suffering
I care more about quality of life than
quantity of life
in her more dramatic moments she would
say John if I ever get that sick just
shoot me
just shoot me
and John rinka would look lovingly at
his wife his healthy wife and he would
say Okay Steph okay
fast forward a couple of decades in her
late 50s
Stephanie begins to slur her words
she goes to see a doctor who runs some
tests
and he diagnoses her with ALS
Lou Gehrig's disease
he tells her it's fatal it's incurable
and he tells her that a day is going to
come when she is no longer able to
breathe on her own
Stephanie being Stephanie decides to
extract as much joy and pleasure from
life as she can she spends time with
friends and family and she gets sicker
she and John spend some time on a
beautiful beach that they both love
but there comes a day when Stephanie in
fact is no longer able to breathe she's
gasping for air and John takes her to
the hospital
and a nurse at the hospital asked
Stephanie Mrs rinka
would you like us to put you on a
ventilator
and Stephanie
says yes
John is flabbergasted they've been
having this conversation for 30 years
surely that's not what Stephanie wants
he doesn't say anything the next morning
he says Steph
when the nurse asked you yesterday if
you wanted to go on a ventilator and you
said yes is that really what you want
and Stephanie rinka said yes
now you might argue that as Stephanie
had written out an advanced directive if
Stephanie had come into the hospital
unconscious if the nurse had asked John
what is it your wife would want John
without hesitation would have said of
course she does not want to go on a
ventilator we should try and figure out
a way to keep her as comfortable as
possible so that she can die with
dignity
but of course this only solves the legal
conundrum it doesn't solve the ethical
problem here and the ethical problem is
that Stephanie at age 39
and she was healthy had no real
conception of what Stephanie at age 59
with a terminal illness gasping for air
would really want
for the older Stephanie her younger self
might as well have been a stranger a
stranger who was trying to make life and
death decisions for her
philosophers have talked
talkers about
experiment it's sometimes called the
ship of Theseus
the great warrior Theseus returned from
his exploits his ship was stationed in
the harbor as a memorial
and over the decades parts of the ship
began to rot and Decay and as this
happened planks were replaced by new
planks until eventually every part of
the ship of Theseus
was built from something new
and philosophers starting with Plato
have asked the question if every part of
the ship of Theseus is new
is this still the ship of Theseus
you and I are walking examples of the
ship of Theseus
our cells turn over all the time the
people you are 10 years ago are not the
people you are today biologically you
have become a different person
but I believe something much more
profound happens at a psychological
level because you could argue a ship is
not just a collection of planks a body
is not just a collection of cells it's
the organization of the planks that
makes the ship it's the organization of
the cells that make the body if you
preserve the organization even if you
swap plancks in in and out or cells in
and out you still have the ship you
still have the same body
but at a psychological level
each new layer that's put down is not
identical to the one that came before it
the famous plasticity of the brain that
we've all heard so much about means that
on an ongoing basis you are constantly
becoming
a new person
this has profound consequences for so
many different aspects of Our Lives you
know I have the illusion
that 12 year old Shankar who wanted to
be a soccer star and 52 year old Shankar
who is the podcast host and 82 year old
Shankar who will hopefully be living one
day on a beautiful beach
that these are all the same person
is that really true
let's set aside the philosophical
questions for another day and let me
tell you about some of the Practical
challenges of this problem
when we make promises to other people
when we promise to love someone till
death to us part we are making a promise
that a stranger is going to have to keep
our future ourselves might not share our
views our perspectives our hopes
when we lock people up and throw away
the key it's not just that the people we
imprison are going to be different in 30
years from now we are going to be
different 30 years from now our need for
Retribution for vengeance might not be
what it is today
when we passed laws
we often do so with an intent of making
a better country improving our country
but any country that's been around for a
few decades has numerous laws in the
books that made perfect sense when they
were crafted in fact they were seen as
enlightened when they were crafted and
today they seem Antiquated or absurd or
even unconscionable
and all of these examples stem from the
same problem which is that we imagine
that we represent the end of History
that the future is only going to be more
of the same
I have three pieces of advice on how to
wrestle with this wicked problem and it
is a wicked problem because all of us
spend so much of our lives trying to
make our future selves happy
we don't stop to ask is it possible that
in 20 or 30 years our future selves are
going to look back at us with
bewilderment with resentment
that our future selves will ask us what
made you possibly think that that is
what I would want
the first piece of advice I have
is if you accept the idea that you're
going to be a different person in 30
years time you should play an active
role crafting the person you are going
to become
you should be the curator of your future
self you should be the architect
of your future self but what does that
mean
spend time with people who are not just
your friends and family spend time on
avocations and professional Pursuits
that are not just what you do regularly
expand your horizons because you're
going to become someone different you
might as well be in charge of deciding
who that person is going to be
so the first piece of advice is to stay
curious
second as we make pronouncements on
social media or in political forums or
at dinner parties
let's bear in mind that among the people
who might disagree with us
are our own future selves
so when we express views with great
certitude and great confidence
let's remember to add a touch of
humility
this is true by the way not just at an
individual level it's also true at an
organizational level I was speaking some
time ago with this young woman
wonderful woman she had just reached a
position of authority at her
organization and she had many idealistic
ideas of how she wanted to change her
organization and she asked me how do we
make these changes so that in the future
no one's going to come along and undo
the changes that I have made
and it's a very human impulse
but it stems from the same belief that
our perspective on history is the final
word
and quite simply
this is wrong
three
I've given you a number of ways in which
our future cells are going to be
weaker and frailer than we are today
and that is true that is part of the
story
but it is only a part of the story
our future cells are also going to have
capacities and strengths and wisdom
that we do not possess today
so when we confront opportunities and we
hesitate
when I tell myself I don't think I have
it in me to quit my job and start my own
company
or I tell myself I don't have it in me
to learn a musical instrument at the age
of 52.
or I tell myself I don't have it in me
to look after a disabled child
what we really should be saying is
I don't have the capacity to do those
things
today
that doesn't mean I won't have the
capacity to do those things tomorrow
so lesson number three
is to be brave
I believe if you can do these three
things
if you can stay curious
if you can practice humility and you can
be brave
then your future self will look back at
you in 20 or 30 years we'll look back
not with resentment or bewilderment
but we'll look back at you and say
thank you
[Applause]